Dave is a 30 year old unemployed man who
spends his entire day working on a
cardboard maze he claims that he is a
good artist but he has never made
anything useful in the first scene we
have shown a recorded clip of Dave's
interview where he states that he built
the maze because he wanted to prove
himself he also regretfully accepts
responsibility for the people that died
because of it the movie then flashes
back to three days in the past Dave's
girlfriend Annie returns from a trip she
notices a giant structure made of
cardboard boxes in her living room when
she calls out for Dave he responds from
inside the box he welcomes her back home
and tells her that he built the
Labyrinth all by himself you turned on
honey and he then excuses herself and
goes to take a shower however when she
returns she sees that Dave is still in
the box he explains that he has been
working on the box all weekend and he
has lost his way puzzled and he reminds
him that it's just cardboard and he can
easily come out of it by knocking it all
over however Dave claims that the
structure is much bigger from the inside
and he doesn't want to tear it down
because it took him so long to make it
and he grows impatient and she proceeds
to enter but Dave forbids her saying
that it's too dangerous frustrated she
starts to shake the cardboard boxes
however this causes the things inside
the structure to fall over and Dave
starts screaming pleading with her to
stop you're gonna make me come and he
backs down but she insists on coming in
however Dave once again forbids her
saying that she will be lost looking at
the situation Annie asks how long he has
been inside the cardboard and the latter
replies that it's been three days Annie
who has become worried at this point
suggests he break the structure down but
Dave is adamant on finding another way
hence left with no options Annie calls
his friend Gordon for help after a while
Gordon comes over and Annie explains
everything to him from inside the Box
Dave also mentions that no one should
come inside yet as the maze isn't
complete he then explains the beauty of
the structure saying that he started
from the center and built outward like a
seashell as Annie and Gordon discussed
the situation the latter mentions that
it's very typical of Dave to start
something and leave it unfinished they
also wonder where he is defecating
inside Dave overhears the conversation
and responds that he actually hasn't
eaten in three days hearing this and he
gets worried so Gordon tries to lift the
cardboard but just then things start to
shake violently as if there is some sort
of machine inside the maze left with no
choice Gordon decides to seek help from
their mutual friend Leonard however he
ends up calling others too the others
include Harry the journalist and his
crew siblings Greg and Brynn over
enthusiastic Jane two Belgian tourists
and a homeless man Dave warns everyone
against breaking or entering the maze
saying that it's too dangerous because
of the obstacles and booby traps this
frustrates Leonard and he decides to
return home as Dave refuses to let him
help keep your boobies to yourself then
Dave in the next scene Annie starts to
worry and Dave apologizes to her for
putting her through this he says that he
misses her and although she is set with
him she admits that she too Misses him
and he finally has had enough and she
decides to go inside the maze to bring
him out this is music to Harry's ears
and he starts to film everything for his
documentary when the others learn about
Annie's Adventure everyone except the
homeless man decides to give her company
once the group enters they all realize
that Dave was telling the truth and the
structure is much bigger than it looks
from outside Gordon also gets a taste of
the maze when he accidentally slits his
finger and his blood is strongly
absorbed by the cardboard floor Jane and
the others start to explore the maze on
their own while Harry and his crew
follow Annie and Gordon around they look
for Dave but soon realize that the maze
is more complicated than they thought as
they try to figure out their path Harry
comes across a button on the wall with a
warning against pressing it however he
nonchalantly presses it and the next
second Gordon is hit with a ball next
the group comes across a hallway which
leads to a musical room the room has
keyboards painted on the wall however
they discover that they can Venture into
the wall Through The Black Keys the wall
leads the group to a pit full of
discarded paper with two origami birds
watching over them from the balcony soon
one of the birds lunges at them sending
everyone into panic mode the door to the
room also closes and Annie starts
looking for another way out she notices
a giant face sculptor on the wall and
helps everyone Escape through its mouth
Annie is shaken by the ordeal and she
struggles to cope with the fact that the
origami are Alive Harry tries to film
her reaction on camera but they are soon
interrupted by Jane who comes running
into the room she excitedly tells
everyone that she is having fun
exploring the maze but right then she
mistakenly steps on a Bobby trap a booby
trap the Trap activates and her head is
separated from her body much to
everyone's horror however instead of
blood yarn and confetti spills out of
Jane's body witnessing this everyone
panics and runs out of the room the
scene then cuts to Greg and Brynn
playing hide and seek inside the maze by
themselves unfortunately in the process
Greg mistakenly acted it's another booby
trap and he is sandwiched between the
wall and a spiked Grill instantly
killing him shortly after Bryn notices
his dead body much to her horror to make
matters worse she is splashed with a
strange pink substance elsewhere Annie
starts to get upset and complains why
Dave built the booby traps Gordon
explains that without the traps the maze
would simply be a series of articulated
hallways soon they are joined by a
frightened Brin she reveals what
happened to Greg and takes everyone to
the place where he was killed however to
everyone's astonishment Greg's Body is
found missing and a trail of blood and
giant footsteps are leading out of the
room after examining the scene Gordon
deduces that the footsteps belong to a
man eating half bull half-human monster
called Guy Fieri uh the Minotaur and he
finally has had enough and she decides
to make a hole through the cardboard
wall with a knife to get everyone out of
the maze lo and behold wind starts to
blow and they hear loud noises as if
they are trying to stop her from tearing
open the wall Annie eventually succeeds
but only to realize that there's another
room on the other side of the wall
sensing the incoming danger Annie and
the others quickly Venture into the room
but something catches the attention of
Brynn and she stays back everyone asks
her to come but with a swift move the
giant monster swoops her up killing her
afraid for their lives the group flees
the scene and they finally run into Dave
and he then leads them through a small
door which takes them to a strange room
consisting of a table and chair made of
cardboard paper after reaching safety
Annie and Dave get into an argument and
everyone blames him for their
predicament Dave mentions that he warns
them against entering but nonetheless he
promises to get them out he then asks
everyone to follow him into a secret
door but ends up leading them through a
pipe which turns them into cardboard
characters Annie and the others demand
answers from Dave and he assures them
that it's going to be okay after they
get back to the apartment but right then
the giant shows up prompting the group
to run for their lives Dave leads them
out of the room and this I'm something
good finally happens when they cross a
tunnel they all come out in their normal
forms the Minotaur also follows them
outside but Dave builds a temporary wall
to turn him away in the next scene the
situation again starts to heat up
everyone wants to escape the Maze and
they all start to argue with one another
when things get out of hand Dave steps
up and reveals that in order to escape
they have to complete building the
unfinished maze however Annie refuses to
let him come I mean continue oh gosh and
instead orders him to lead them out of
the maze they've reluctantly agrees and
as they try to find a way out they come
across a strange wall surprisingly Dave
notes that he doesn't recall building it
meanwhile Leonard returns home and he
too enters the mace unfortunately the
first thing he sees is the minotaur's ax
and Jane's severed head lying on the
ground as he walks away it's shown that
a giant origami insect has clung onto
his back elsewhere Dave takes Andy and
the others to the entertainment room
where he shows them the old British
entertainment he then takes them to
another peculiar room with a strange
enticing opening on the wall it has a
hypnotizing effect and Annie and the
others are drawn towards it however Dave
warns them to stay away from it when the
others don't listen to him Dave Reveals
His Hand which is turned into cardboard
after he stuck it into the opening the
group then continues their Journey Only
to realize that the maze has started to
grow by itself overwhelmed by the
strange incidents Dave loses it and
calls for everyone's help in killing the
giant so that he can finish building the
Maze and finally head home unfortunately
the group turns the idea down and even
in such a horrible situation Harry
suggests taking Dave's interview for the
documentary the latter reluctantly
agrees but he pours his heart out during
the interview he admits that he hates
himself for being an unemployed 30 year
old who is still dependent on his
parents for everything it turns out he
built the maze so people including his
parents could realize that he too can do
something he also apologizes for the
people that died in The Maze hearing his
emotional Outburst Annie becomes emotion
optional too and Promises to help him
get out of the maze the group then
starts thinking about the Escape Plan
again with a newfound interest Gordon
notes that since the maze is somehow
alive and growing it must have a heart
which they could find and kill Dave
agrees and says that everything usually
has a weak spot but unfortunately he
didn't build one for the maze because he
didn't want anyone to destroy it in
response Gordon comments that Dave
didn't finish the maze because you can't
fail if you don't finish anything
however Annie empathizes with her
boyfriend and explains that everyone has
to deal with failure and it's a part of
life that is absolutely true she then
encourages him to build the Chrysalis so
they could destroy it and get out
following this Dave and the group again
start exploring the Maze and they come
across Brynn who was killed earlier she
is now turned into a paper toll and is
tied to the wall Bryn asks the group for
high fives but knowing that it's most
likely a trap they refuse to give her
any Dave and Danny continue to look for
their destination while Gordon and the
rest stay behind to distract bran in the
next scene Dave and Danny walk for
several minutes until they come across a
dark tunnel the movie then cuts to a
scene where Dave and Danny are having a
conversation where Annie continues to
play the role of a successful woman
while Dave stays a bum the scenario
keeps changing but they are still happy
to be together back in the dark tunnel
the couple reaches the center of the
maze they then start to build the heart
of the maze after completing it Annie
uses a sword to hack through the
cardboard wall Gordon and others sense
this and they promptly tie up bran to
keep her from attacking Annie however
Brynn transforms into a giant hand and
Retreats back into the ground in the
process the cameraman gets dragged into
it but not before he heroically saves
all his equipment not a boy the rest of
the group then proceeds to join Annie
and Dave at the center however on their
way there Gordon gets separated from the
others when he is chased by the giant
Minotaur Annie and Dave set up the heart
as Harry and his team capture the moment
as the heart Comes Alive the Minotaur
continues to Chase Gordon during which
he Witnesses Leonard getting killed by
cardboard blades back at the center of
the maze Dave strikes the heart with the
sword and destroys it finally the entire
thing starts to fall apart and the group
emerges from the rubbish everyone is
safe now but Dave is upset about
destroying his hard work Harry cheers
him up and tells him that at least he
has a documentary to look forward to
chin up your friends died for you you
prick the group then cleans the mess and
dumps the scraps outside as they leave
the Minotaur emerges from the scrap
along with an origami bird ready to take
revenge on humankind subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching